Mr chair we're ready when you are thank
you very much
for the record uh my name is Joseph
Malik I'm the chairman of the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission with me is
our CEO James Vera I'd just like to say
that I have informed the governor of
this model I had a meeting with the
governor on this model and didn't inform
him and he's fully informed that we're
going to testify on it today the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission does not
take a position on this and we're here
as a resource for the committee
so
starting on page one
you'll notice that we're calling this a
franchise model because that's what it
is
on page two the introduction is just
to give you some history of the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission our primary
duels rules our and Duties are under
176.3 to optimize profitability maintain
proper controls and assume
responsibility for an effective and
efficient operation of the Liquor
Commission and you can see that in 2022
we generated over 771 million dollars in
Revenue
take you to page three just a simple
graph of our Revenue since our Inception
95 years ago that we've put over four
and a half billion dollars into the
general fund you can see that since
covid we've had a little drop off
uh just some historical perspective
there as the Baby Boomers drop out of
the alcohol control Market uh this the
sales in general across the states
you're seeing the oldest Boomers at 77
the youngest Boomers at 59. it's a big
segment of the liquor Market that's
moving out of the market so we're seeing
a little decline Nationwide
maybe maybe this information will come
but when it comes to sales of liquor to
out-of-state residents or or out of
state customers do you have any idea
what the perhaps percentages to
out-of-state consumers shorts it's a
little over 50 percent and we're
actually in the process we haven't done
a full survey since 2014 or in the
process of doing another full survey now
it's a little over 50 percent
cross-border sales
okay thank you
I follow a question about you I'm sorry
thank you sorry to stop you so early
um but there's a big number on page two
that the commission had generated a
substantial amount of money in net sales
and
um so I'm just curious of of that number
of net sales what was actually
transferred to the general fund and
other funds in terms of Revenue back to
the state
thank you thank you
so you'll see on page four that where
the revenue sources come from liquor and
wine Revenue sources restaurants Lounge
grocery stores
the beer tax and permits and the other
Revenue which is fees including some
miscellaneous Lottery Revenue
on page five you'll see the
organizational structure of the Liquor
Commission the office of the commission
the division of enforcement the number
of people in the enforcement division
the administrative Division and the
marketing Division and those 298 people
about 260 of those folks are in our
stores in our Outlets
so we can see down the bottom a little
further breakdown of those positions
the divisions UH responsibilities you've
got the office of the commission I won't
read the responsibilities you've got the
division of enforcement the division of
administration and the division of
marketing basically we run an 800
Million Dollar business 50 of our
business comes from cross-border our
major competitors Total Wine and Spirits
uh they moved into Massachusetts in
2016. they now have seven locations in
Massachusetts Massachusetts is their
fastest growing state every one of their
locations save one is inside the 495
Beltway
they are in
they have
243 stores in 24 States so they are the
largest private liquor and wine retailer
in the United States and that is our
major competition they're owned by Two
Brothers the trone brothers
one of them is uh Congressman in
Virginia
just as a little FYI
our 65 retail outlet locations as you
can see
across the state you can see that we
purposely put them along the border we
track them along the southern part of
the state
and
we also have three agency stores one in
Greenville one in Pittsburgh and one in
Arrow New Hampshire
if you still mind explaining when you
say agency store me to explain what
exactly the agency towards the door
an agency stores a licensee where the
commission has felt there hasn't been an
agency store licensed since
2002.03
03 there hasn't been an agency store
license put out
um an agency stores someone that buys
their product directly from the
commission at wholesale and sells to the
general public with a markup that they
deem is responsible for the area that
they are in so we do not oversee
the profits that an agency store makes
they're allowed to mark up uh whatever
they they deem necessary they cannot
undersell the Commission in what they do
and given that there's only three of
them I think they do around two and a
half million dollars collectively all
three stores with the model that we've
put in place since I've been at the
Commission in 2010 uh creating a brand
creating a look and feel uh we don't
necessarily feel that that's something
that we need to do on the liquor side of
the business but it's out there and it
certainly works
you can see with the alcohol system we
have the three-tier system is in place
in the state of New Hampshire
manufacturers are there we have Brokers
and wholesalers in the state and the
obviously the Liquor Commission is the
retailer
so now we'll get into on page nine uh
the idea of recreational adult use
cannabis framework so we have Growers
Growers can take on many looks and feels
from small farm Growers to large
Greenhouse Growers and everything in
between
manufacturing is the manufacturing of
edible products the dabs the Vapes the
gummies
Etc
and what the model that we are looking
to put into place that we feel would be
feasible is that the Liquor Commission
would be the franchisor
and the franchisee would be the retailer
much like any other franchise system
that we set up
across the country be it a McDonald's
via Dunkin Donuts be it Whatever It Is
there'd be a certain look and feel
and we would I'll get into it further
but we would oversee and organize that
look and feel as well as all the safety
aspects of selling the product
so on page 10 you'll see the additional
uh number of uh people that we feel the
Liquor Commission would need we'd need
an additional 10 people in the division
of enforcement for obviously licensing
education and enforcement some
additional people in finance under the
director of administration Human
Resources auditing I.T and legal and
some people in the marketing and
Merchandising because as the franchisor
we will take on all the marketing and
the message that's put out to the public
so and the main thing that we feel that
we need to do is obviously from a
federal standpoint we're we're
separating the two businesses they're
going to be run completely separate
they're going to be marketed completely
separately and the look and feel in some
in some instances would be similar but
they would not take on the same
structure where we would put
state employees into these stores to
actually run the stores
so I'll move on to page 10.
I'm sorry
under your structure
this is not going to be in the liquid
store itself it's going to be a
freestanding facility is that's the way
you're seeing it well I can in the next
couple of pages representative I'll get
into the idea of of how we're going to
look at it as from a business standpoint
but that's correct you made a comment
about separating any thought twice sure
that the finance division will be
completely separated the marketing
division will be completely separated
the enforcement division will be
completely separated they'll fall under
the umbrellas that we now have in place
but a liquor investigator will not do
cannabis work there'll be two separate
investigators uh an auditor of cannabis
will not be an auditor of liquor a
marketing person of liquor will not be a
marketing person of cannabis they will
be completely separated
and follow up on that oh so you also
indicated in order to uh sidestep or to
avoid uh confrontation with Federal uh
um things put it easily
what's the Genesis of that if you could
please her
well the Genesis is uh is basically the
the law itself if the federal government
ever has an issue with cannabis in any
way shape or form beyond what we've seen
now and we've seen very little uh we
certainly wouldn't want them to close
down the liquor business okay because we
were in the Cannabis business we wanted
we would want those to remain completely
separate and and with all due respect oh
I'm not looking at I'm looking at as a
as a preemptive business move rather
than anything else yeah that's that's
fine representative kale
thank you for taking my question sure
marijuana is federally illegal correct
as far as I know thank you
um you might
um is it possible that we could get a a
uh our cost of these uh 29 people 30
people sure I believe we had some costs
in the original legislation but yeah
just just sure break it up off the top
of my head I don't know no no that's
certainly your job certainly something
that we can do I wasn't looking at
yourself yeah thank you yeah certainly
happy to do that
uh yeah thanks for taking my question so
you said in the in the people working in
the stores would not be state employees
that's correct so the only view the
people in the administrative structure
enforcement division marketing Division
and administration Division and the
people in the stores would be the
responsibility of the franchisee okay so
just like any other franchise it sounds
good you have a home headquarters the
stores are a responsibility of the
franchisee any of the uh business that
goes on under the roof of that under
that business this is the responsibility
of the franchisee
I'd like to ask one question about sure
it came to when it comes to the liquor
investigate Gators and you know we'll
just call it when the Cannabis
investigators for now what's the
rationale to keep I understand keeping
the finances separate but how why keep
the enforcement separate
the there's a completely different level
of expertise in what we're looking at
so that would be the reason different
training different uh rationale of
business and and different level of
expertise
thank you you're welcome
generally so feel free to tell me you're
going to cover this later but so I I
under the franchisees model and the
private employees does that extend the
AG to be able to defend if the federal
government came in any employee was
charged a distribution under a federal
model
um it's a private business so no so no
the AG would not be able to defend the
state's position of legalized cannabis
I'm sorry we wouldn't be able to defend
an employee of a franchise absent
um it being a state employee that's
correct
and just I know the Federal
prohibitions have always been a big
talking point if the federal government
decides to
now enforce this particular federal law
and only targets the state of New
Hampshire that would be a very odd I
mean how many I don't have it on top of
my head how many states are doing the
therapeutic programs already and how
many states have done retail already I
mean California Oregon Washington's
entire strip of the length of the
country and they're all doing Recreation
and therapeutic so if they're going to
start here in New Hampshire
I would find that to be odd and be
curious why they took that road so I
think which I understand what the
federal law is but maybe we've
I understand the purpose of the
presentation that comes up but we all
know it's against federal law it's
against the federal law and we're
carrying on for despite that
foreign
we're not the first state that's
considered doing this so when we look at
these models we're absolutely looking in
other states so in this case uh if you
were to look at a government
inter-involved in regulating marijuana
let's say Washington State or Oregon
State
um absolutely they have these same you
know enforcement divisions they have all
the same same things you know they might
have the the product has been sold
licensing is regulated differently but
at the end of the day there's the same
uh enforcement division
thank you okay so on page 11
the Cannabis Growers and manufacturers
facilities shall be New Hampshire based
and operated just like they are in any
other state
what what's grown in the state what's
manufactured in the state stays in the
state no cross-border as far as the
growing or manufacturing is concerned
Cannabis Testing this is done in a lot
of states is done by a third party
individual it's done in Maine that way
and many other states which was an RFP
process and then we'd have a third party
testing facility
Growers and manufacturers would be
licensed by the state of New Hampshire
and inspected by the division of
enforcement and Licensing
the Cannabis pricing oversight would
occur at the wholesale level in
consultation with the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission we're not setting the
price we're Consulting on the price
Growers manufacturers and retailers
would be responsible for the
distribution of cannabis and
transportation much like New Hampshire
Wineries and New Hampshire distilleries
which are allowed to self-distribute
The Growers and the manufacturers would
be allowed to self-distribute to the
retailers it would be no different than
what we had the way we have it set up
for New Hampshire wineries or New
Hampshire distilleries
so there'd be a sure uh just help me
understand because I I've talked a lot
with growers in past years
what if there's a bad crop we get a
rainy year or for some reason they don't
Harvest can we buy out of state to fill
our needs so that we we couldn't sell
that year a lot of the the growing is
done indoor Greenhouse okay the majority
of the growing is done indoor Greenhouse
in controlled settings the product
Stacks as a seed it's given a SKU number
it works through the whole plate so the
whole process from being abud to being a
full plant from the trim from that plant
to the manufacturing and that
manufacturing piece goes into the
Edibles there there's certainly an
opportunity for outside Growers to grow
on small plots of land and harvest their
their products but the majority of what
you see when you get to a level that we
intend to be at without the seats that
surround us is indoor grow facilities
if I could ask a question in respect to
the requirement that it be grown and
manufactured in New Hampshire I
appreciate the reason for that obviously
when you start crossing over state
borders you put me around to some other
Federal issues
again I would be surprised with their
enforcement but who knows right but my
my thought was
if we didn't have that restriction you
couldn't buy it out of state anyway or
sell it because you'll be filing that
State's law so perhaps if there's a
reason we kind of being neutral on that
because if one day that were to change
we kind of would be able to hit the
floor running rather than have to
legislate a change which I think we can
agree the
with all the respect to my colleagues
the legislator tends to work slow yeah
there's nothing in the bill that
actually bars it okay it's always been
treated this is an FTC you know Federal
Trade Commission regulation it was a
shock to me when I first got involved
was to find out that every state is
really lit everybody's within their live
within their own state but you're
absolutely right the the issue would be
is that you're buying across the state
line and uh but but at this point in
time we we would not want to borrow
ourselves from if that Federal rule were
to change if at some point in time we
would absolutely would want to be able
to import it and keeping in mind if a
retail would purchase from Maine or
Massachusetts they're going to have a
they're filing that State's law and so
with the distributor so they I mean they
would they would have their own problems
that they have to deal with it's not in
this state I don't know if there's any
comment on that policy or anyone have
any
I always like to say that what makes our
liquor stores very unique
is that we um actually do very well with
out-of-state product
and that New Hampshire we like to try
our best we've promoted we've actually
passed legislation to force them to put
New Hampshire products on the front of
the store but let's face it we do not
have name brand right we go to Total the
competitor we do not have our own name
brand vodkas or anything like that we
are selling out of state products
thank you
a few questions about
HIV model with respect season licensing
manufacturing and growing so
um
[Music]
okay I hit it twice okay thank you
um so I'm not a franchisee so I'm going
to need a little help here so it's my
impression that
franchisees as you propose in this model
are required to buy product from a
licensed um
producer of let's say hamburgers or
french fries that are acceptable to the
corporation would that be would that be
correct in this model that's correct
okay so
um
who in this model would be responsible
for testing to determine whether or not
um the licensed manufacturer products
that would be sold to franchisees would
be harmful or not harmful to the public
third-party testing would be done on
every product that leaves any
manufacturer or grower okay so then the
licensee
that would be allowed to grow would be a
license under the regulation and the
authority of the Liquor Commission
correct that's correct okay has the
Liquor Commission developed a plan
and regulations or looked at
allowable chemicals and pesticides and
there are allowable amounts
that could be found and should be tested
for
in any franchisee product no we have not
and the reason that we have not is
because the legislation calls for a
consultant that would help to guide The
Liquor Commission on those parameters
have you looked at the current status of
what health Canada
has produced with respect to the
identification of more than 100
allowable and unallowable chemicals and
pesticides I've looked at many different
States including Canada as to what they
allow and that would be the job of the
consultant that we would hire to guide
The Liquor Commission as to what we
would allow and not allow
do you have any idea what the cost would
be for
inspecting on and testing for franchisee
products that are sold through the state
franchisee system
in other words if you're proposing 65
Outlets that is one outlet for
approximately every 18
646 residents of the State of New
Hampshire what uh is the projected cost
both in terms of personnel that would be
required to obtain the samples set up a
sampling testing scheme the number of
Representative samples per site or per
grow or per acre and then submit those
to a testing laboratory license or
approved by the state that would be a
cost correct correct and do you have any
idea what that cost would be no because
we don't have any idea what the
legislation looks like yet when the
legislation comes into play then we can
put the costs into play our our purpose
is to be here today to explain a model
that's very unique and would be unique
to the state of New Hampshire and that
as business people we feel would be
profitable and safe for the state
would it be fair to say then though that
to determine profitability it would be
necessary to determine or at least
ballpark the cost of let's say an
aggregate amount of product that would
be anticipated that would be sold based
on some experiential models of other
states
I would say that's fair but that model
in terms of cost per testing and
Regulatory Authority has not been
conducted correct that's correct thank
you you're welcome
thank you Mr chair so
under your model
everything would be grown and
manufactured in New Hampshire it has to
be it has to be that's a federal yeah
yeah I I understand the tax history and
the original tax stamp one yeah yeah I
understand that the testing would then
be determined by it would be to be
determined by the consultant that we
would hire us or what those were based
upon available evidence at the time all
right and depending on what the final
legislation comes up with correct
the manufacturing facility for the uh
uh non-raw product
for the Edibles for lack of a better
term
or ingredients for baking or whatever
else
would be
who would examine that structure or is
that still in the air or that would that
be done by the Department of Agriculture
or or one of one of the agencies within
here
that would be done by the consultant as
well the consultant would we would get
the parameters for the consultant
as as what they feel is safe and what we
see that other states are doing and then
the parameters anything that leaves a
manufacturing or growing facility would
have to meet those parameters and would
be governed by The Liquor Commission
enforcement division to make sure that
those products meet those parameters
right and follow thank you Mr chair and
um
how do I put this without getting in
trouble I understand
that
different products have different uh
composite structures
who would be responsible for
establishing the labeling which would
specify THC CBD participation whether
it's indica or sativa or nocturna or
erotica or whatever blend they make the
in consultation with the consultant The
Liquor Commission would be responsible
for that for the design and then the the
retailer would have to have that
labeling on which your Enforcement
Officers would check on is that correct
that's correct and that's further into
the the deck
thank you thank you Mr chairman
yes just one one thought one it was some
issue brought up on the fiscal side or
on a profitability perspective
I know prior bills the fiscal note I'm
going to involved retail candidates they
had a fiscal note with an anticipated
amount of sales I'm not sure how those
numbers were configured and if the
purposes of 1598
I mean some of the testimony I provided
was based on taking looking at prior
fiscal notes so if you look at last term
HB 237
uh that would have had a fiscal law on
the retail side without it being
operated by state employees but I I
don't know how that number actually
first came about I don't know if anyone
can dig that up but representative way
so that bill was in ways and means and I
think if we remember right Chief Mr
commissioner was what we um
looked at the other states and what they
were doing including the fact that we
understand that some of the sales are
out of state employees out of state
visitors but they looked at what the
gross sales was divided by the number of
citizens they had to come out with with
the average cost per citizen is of
Revenue and then they extrapolated that
based on New Hampshire's Revenue that's
how we came up with our I think it was
250 million dollars last year in gross
sales that we thought based on
what we saw in other states and what um
and based it on the Hampshire's uh per
capita thank you Chief yes thank you Mr
chair one follow-up question uh who
would uh make the determination to
identify and hire the consultant
I it would be an RFP and the Liquor
Commission would make that determination
thank you
so I just want to make sure we're kind
of wrap it wrap up all of that
conversation so in short The Liquor
Commission and consultant in
consultation with with an industry
expert would establish what the testing
standards would look like than those
testing standards would be applied to
the product whatever it was whatever its
source was to all the product and they
would make sure it would meet that
criteria and then it would finally make
its way into the retail Market that's
correct thank you
okay and and Senator that would be after
the product was tested by the third
party lab so okay thank you
all right
so we'll move on to page 12.
and there would be a franchise agreement
between the retailer and the New
Hampshire Liquor Commission
as part of the franchise agreement the
retailer shall provide the nhlc with 15
percent of the gross monthly sales of
their individual establishment to be
paid on a quarterly basis so that's
where the state
would profit from the sales of cannabis
in the state the stored design and setup
would be through the New Hampshire
Liquor Commission and their vendors to
ensure a consistent branding and
reputation so we would go out for an RFP
for someone to provide the cases the
signage the look the feel of the store
there'd be no more retail locations than
the number of New Hampshire liquor and
wine outlets in the state
and we've there has been a map that
showed you where they were and there can
be no more retail locations uh I'm sorry
than the 65.
and the retailers and vendors for design
would be selected through an RFP process
so
as we go out and look for people to run
these locations we'd send out an RFP and
obviously there'd be some stands that
have more than one Outlet Nashua for
example as for liquor and wine outlets
they would have four Cannabis stores
Concord has two liquor and wine outlets
they'd have two Cannabis stores and if
we came if we had a jurisdiction that
did not want a cannabis store in their
town then we would go to the surrounding
towns first and search those towns for a
town that wanted to have a cannabis
store
on page 13 the retailers will not be in
the same liquor locations as a liquor
and wine outlet and we would absolutely
prefer that they weren't in the same
um the same malls the same locations in
order to
not coincide with any cross-pollination
between the liquor stores and the
Cannabis stores the retailers shall not
be located in residential districts or
within pre-existing design drug-free
school zones the Cannabis and marketing
shall be done by The Liquor Commission
and the municipalities can determine an
opt-in to have a cannabis retailer and
the municipalities shall receive one
percent of the 15 percent growth uh
monthly sales provided to The Liquor
Commission so before we go on I do have
a question sure I'm sorry so
um
it just dawn on me we're we're creating
these franchisees
and we're doing all the marketing
but part of marketing is actually
pricing
correct so I'm not asking you to have
tell us what we do today but I would say
as as someone who sits on the the
committee that's dealt with these issues
over the years uh we would be uh
interested in how you're going to handle
in-store marketing
in terms of whether someone wants to
give a price discount you know whether
they want to have a special price uh the
one I heard today when I was in
Massachusetts was this weekend was at a
store uh Wednesday Wednesday is Veterans
Day and they give a five percent
discount to veterans
so in terms of how at some point I'm
thinking about all these little integral
elements of these franchisees
um because I assume we don't want to see
a franchisee trying to out franchise
outsell another franchisee because
you're doing all the marketing in terms
of they can't advertise
outside other than what they do inside
the store so that we'll need some
guidelines on what they can and can't do
inside that store well we would create
much like we do with alcohol we would
create a marketing design in a marketing
scheme and we would do either a monthly
marketing
or a a weekly marketing we certainly
allow them to to put something special
on on special and discount it one of the
unique things here is we're dealing with
a product that is is moisture intense so
what it what it's what it's worth today
and the value and weight today is
different than it is two weeks later so
we have to make sure that those
franchisees have the availability
to Discount the product so they remain
profitable move stuff that needs to be
moved because of its age cool that
doesn't necessarily uh take into account
uh the Edibles because we don't
necessarily see that problem with the
edibles but with the flour and the shape
or the bud any of that would they we'd
have to make sure that the franchisees
uh have the ability to Discount the
product in order to remain profitable
right but again it's going to be across
the board by all franchisees or well
individual franchisees be able to do
something special in their location they
would be able to do something special in
their location provided that the Liquor
Commission agreed to it because you're
not going to have every franchisee carry
every every one of the same products
right and the cost of doing business in
Colebrook is much different than the
cost of doing business in Bedford so
we're going to have to allow those
franchisees to to represent their
brought their markup scheme a little bit
differently depending on what area they
can good and because I realize there's a
little down in the weeds here but it's
just something that I know acutely aware
of it it's a it's a legitimate question
because in any franchise model you know
a Big Mac is a Big Mac it's 529 in
Pittsburgh uh well I was very happy that
they brought back the two burritos for
breakfast that I have knowledge at three
dollars at 5 29 in Tampa so but with
this particular product you can't do it
the franchisee model of what we're
looking at has to do more with the
advertising and the uh enforcement look
at how we're going to do it
the discussion that uh representative
Pond brought up
um
brought to mind
we already have an existing and uh
modestly growing
um medical marijuana
group of facilities how are these going
to be integrated into that will they be
a lot will they be separated within the
store or separated by sale or or does
that just go by the buy because you're
no longer needing the medical card no I
think what would be taken into
consideration would be somebody's
experience in business and the location
of the business we're certainly not in a
in a position or do we want to pick
winners and losers but those facilities
would be allowed to uh
apply for a retail license as well and
obviously being that they've been in
business and they have experience in
business would be favorable for their uh
application
and nothing would debar the continuation
of their operation I'm sorry nothing
would prevent them from continuing in
operation with this even if they decided
not to go Whole Hog not as far as we're
concerned no representative
if I can inquire the question and I
certainly appreciate trying to keep the
brand of the liquor stores the New
Hampshire runs keep that apart from any
cannabis store that's franchised
I I didn't hear you say that perhaps you
wouldn't even want them to be in the
same strip mall the same facility like
that I guess my my concern is
uh I was thinking I was just thinking 93
and 95 when you said that well first and
foremost we we we're putting that caveat
in there because we're not sure how our
landlords feel the landlords in those
particular locations feel like we have
one particular landlord who doesn't want
to have gambling in their in their strip
malls so we we certainly don't want to
you know make uh you know put our
landlords in a difficult position where
we have long-term leases with a liquor
store if they choose not to have
cannabis in their facility then we look
for another facility so I think the
easiest way to do that is to separate it
and then to find out later if somebody
wants or something's available and
they're willing then we can look at it
but we certainly don't want to say we
want them right next to every liquor
store that we have because you know 58
of our liquor stores are leased so I
just follow up because I think the
problem is the word location yeah
okay okay so as we know the uh 93-95 the
highways correct are actually not run by
the commission you are a tenant in those
locations and that they're actually
their state state uh real estate so the
question would be is could we open up on
those roadsides not in the same building
but another stand-alone building I think
it could be a marijuana and that's where
I think the word location and assuming
the landlord or the was was just the
state the transportation yes and just to
back up just a little bit representative
uh we own our facilities North the
building itself yeah but aren't you
isn't the building at least the to the
uh we we own the 20 000 square feet that
the liquor store sits on We Own the
Liquor Commission owners Irving owned
their lot no they do not they're 10
they're a tenant everyone else there is
a tenant of dot okay
can we put one of these that word
location implies it can't be there at
all and I don't I'm not sure that's what
you meant well I think what we're as I
said what we were trying to do is to
make sure that we weren't putting any
pressure or any innuendo toward our
landlords of our liquor stores now if
DLT decides they think it's a great idea
to have a cannabis store North and South
which I would imagine they would but
then they would we would build a
facility there The Liquor Commission
doesn't own that property anymore we
sold it when we did the RFP we own our
20 000 square feet and we pay a cam
common area maintenance fee on the
facility now when we did the Hampton
Northbound and southbound that caveat
could be put in the RFP that we would
allow to a liquor store to be Northbound
and Southbound liquor stores as for
whoever buys that property again we will
fold our 25
000 square foot locations when we do
those stores that the state will own
okay thank you for the clarification
so again to summarize some of that
um
is your intent in that first bullet to
say that it won't be inside the liquor
store or could it be in the same ship
mall if the if the property owner allows
for marijuana the goal of that was to
mainly do just that it can't be inside
but it can be within the same facility
over our store yeah that's correct your
word location means inside the liquor
store itself correct thank you
thank you
so on page 14 we'll uh
we can go through some of the uh The
Liquor Commission division of
enforcement and Licensing
um
so a warning label there's some
standardized uh all cannabis products
sold by retail Cannabis stores shall
include warning label caution when eaten
or swallowed intoxicating effects a
disclosure of ingredients and possible
allergens a nutritional piano a fact
panel an opaque child resistant
Packaging
um
and on page 16
you can see some of the standardized
labeling and packaging which is used in
other states uh it's quite different
obviously Maine and Massachusetts have
what they have Washington Nevada
Etc everybody's is a little different
but there's certainly a call out there
a requirement from page 17 a requirement
for advertising to include a standard
recognizable symbol AS we've shown
before a Prohibition on anything that's
marketed or is designed of logos you
know we do the same thing with liquor we
we don't there's there's no labels on
our shelves that we feel are child
friendly or offensive to the public
so anything that you know bubble gum
flavored etc etc we can go through that
type of thing the testing should also
verify the THC and other cannabis
potency representative representations
on the correct labeling
requires all retail stores to inform
post informational posters about the
risks of cannabis use the risk during
pregnancy and breastfeeding the risk to
Adolescence in younger buyers and the
posters will be scientifically accurate
all cannabis and cannabis products sold
by retail cannabis store shall have a
warning label this product has an
intoxicating effect for use by adults 21
or older and keep Out Of Reach of
children and unlike alcohol
there will be no sampling giveaways for
tastings so that will be prohibited with
cannabis and the requirements and
processes shall all be outlined in rule
as rule is written
on page 19
product approval process
cannabis licensee selling cannabis in
the state required information the fees
the application forms label content with
THC potency serving size
required warning labels and package size
the commission shall approve all of the
labeling and all the packaging to make
sure that there's no false statements or
any statements that that are subliminal
or deceptive
uh
on page 20 the packaging
uh shall not be duplicative of athletes
or misleading that imply the consumption
of cannabis is conducive to an athletic
skill or physical prowess or consuming
cannabis does not hinder an athlete's
performance the packaging or labeling
features illustration subject matter
Etc are consistent with marketing toward
youth or children that would obviously
be prohibited
the packaging and labeling features
consumption of cannabis products while
seeded about to enter operating or about
to operate an audible deal or machinery
and aspects of the packaging labeling
normalizes or encourages excessive
consumption
the packaging and labeling does not
indicate in a manner significantly clear
that the products contain cannabis and
cannabis products
and then
thank you for taking my question with
regards to the bullet points about
labeling that would not normalize the
use of cannabis I do have a concern then
by placing a nutrition label onto canvas
products that it does in a way normalize
it or otherwise suggest that this would
be food I understand that part of the
reason for placing a nutritional label
on there for example a candy bar would
be to comply with federal law that we
put nutrition labels on food but then
we've done cut ourselves in a catch-22
we've complied with federal law but not
complied with federal law is there a
need for a nutrition label on these
products
to my understanding most of this
language has been used by other states I
certainly think that you know when you
go into a restaurant today they're
having you put calorie count you know
and all that on even a menu
so I'm not 100 sure whether it would
absolutely need to be done or not
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question
um well we're seeing with these
packaging for the Youth we're seeing
these m m packages and candies all all
across the nation that are literally
designed to just attract kids
um once you say that even gummies
attract kids
like a candy
I I don't really have an opinion yeah
well I can actually tell you that that
they don't do dummies anymore so we call
them gummies people call them gummies
but if you actually look at the product
that's sold in these stores
they're they're often that triangular
shape with it like the Massachusetts has
that triangular shape so not they don't
have little bears and I think the the
point is just because you're selling
what is in the shape of a candy bar it
doesn't have to be labeled and packaged
to look like a candy bar on the outside
what's on the inside is
perhaps one one issue but what's on the
outside packaging I think is the concern
because in the packaging I assume that
it shouldn't look like a candy bar in
its packaging even if that's what it is
in there is that the point
so we're borrowing the the look and feel
of something even I mean I I'll make
sure I get you guys copies of pictures
of candy wrappers with that are they're
basically marijuana products that is
specifically what we're saying we're
going to Bar
that that specifically the packaging
cannot look like or have any confusion
with a normal off the you know candy or
product off the shelf
and and I've seen some of the packaging
and it literally looks like something
you'd see at a checkout Island in a
supermarket so I do find it to be that
blatant to be offensive as well but at
the same time what's inside of it I'm
not sure how you could fix that without
barring it all together but at the same
time I think the packaging is something
we can really focus on both obviously my
friends so I'm your current liquor law
right now we every label
has to be approved by the commission so
that is the exact same process that we
perceive to be used here which is that
when someone is this is a product on the
shelf that label has to be approved by
the commission to decide whether you can
have it in the store and I guess we can
ask while we're here perhaps if you have
any pictures you want to show anyone on
liquid commission whether it's today or
another day you can get those out I'll
certainly give you that opportunity
thank you Mr chair uh packaging versus
uh containerization uh has the
commission looked at or determined
whether or not it was going to impose
any child-proof tamper-proof pack
containerization for any product
yeah in my in my knowledge of all the
products I've looked at that's standard
operating procedure Chief and and let me
just say that this is this is your
legislation this these are your rules
we're just putting a model in front of
you that we feel would be conducive to
the health and safety of the people of
New Hampshire and profitable for the
State of New Hampshire
in all the stores that I've been in
Chief and everything that I've looked at
everything has uh a tamper-proof seal on
it and or a packaging label that says
that it contains THC
and and I One caveat to that is
because the Liquor Commission will be
controlled controlling it and the Liquor
Commission will be in charge of it any
of the product that's manufactured in
this state we would control the labeling
and we would control how we want the
product packaged
thank you for my follow-up
um yes uh packaging and containerization
I think are two separate and distinct
issues
um are you aware that uh last year uh
the New Hampshire Poison Control Center
had over 62 cases of um poisoning by
cannabis and 19 of those involved
juveniles which is the concern for
ensuring that whatever product is sold
that contains THC which could be harmful
medically to um particularly for
juveniles that it be contained in a
proper packaging that is
child proof accessible
my only answer to that Chief would be
that I'm fully aware of the harmful
nature of not only alcohol but cannabis
products and we take our position
seriously and that's why we're here
today to lay out a model to you that we
feel would be best for the State of New
Hampshire
chair thanks for taking my question so I
just actually on the same line I I'll
you know as a parent I also you know
want to make sure we have the
appropriate controls in place for
children absolutely some other states I
believe have required or you could
consider requiring licenses retail
places to sell the lock boxes
that's something that the commission
might want to consider I don't know if
you've considered that looking at other
states it would be a helpful thing I
think in terms of maintaining child
safety so that's both the question and a
comment I don't know if you want to say
anything about that
and I have another question and you can
sell the lock boxes in the store yeah
and it could be a requirement that they
do so I mean we're just sort of thinking
through about how to address these very
very valid concerns about child safety
so that's perhaps an option that we
require those licenses to do that I have
another question
this is a very different topic but um
also related to safety too I know that
there have been a lot of concerns in
this state about various you know vape
shops New York schools and you know
certainly that's an issue that we talk
about a lot in New Hampshire is
availability
um of those products and so
um I just want to ask if you sort of
thought through that issue about these
dual licenses like would a vape shop
then be able to request so is it true
that a vape shop has to get a license
from you that's correct so would they
then could they get another license for
cannabis or would there be that
separation required that's just a
question
tobacco mixed with right
I'm meaning you know if they were
it could have a current existing Vape
Shop apply to get a license to be one of
these franchisees as well
uh Senator I'll just go back to this is
your legislation and and you'll write
the rules well
I can come in it's okay it's a
franchisee
so know that Vape location could never
be
one of these franchisees because they
would have to tear it down and rebuild
it onto our specifications
towards building down made him made
itself now in line with the rules that I
set by the law and right could they then
also sell the vacuum I think
that'd be a problem I think that's is
that your question well I mean and I and
I don't even know so that was a question
like I I think we would put in the bill
we should put it in the bill that no
they cannot sell anything other than
marijuana product DHE products we would
yeah absolutely we wanted to make it
clear that no you could not be getting
tobacco or non a non-thc or CBD type
product baby but I don't know maybe not
CBD either
yeah and I was just curious whether you
all had thought about that and if you
had a position on that in general in
terms of safety we don't have a position
on it okay thanks
thank you
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question uh I understand that
the Liquor Commission will be overseeing
um the marketing and advertising of the
products my question relates to signage
of your friend franchisees signage can
be constituted as advertisement so will
there be a requirement uh or oversight
by the commission on friendship
franchisee signage absolutely there will
be okay the only signage that in our
opinion that will be allowed outside of
the store is the sign that the Liquor
Commission will approve that will be
standard for all franchisees that says
this is a liquor this is a cannabis
Outlet I have uh I'll give you a quick
idea of what we've done uh basically
this will be it
this is what will be outside of those
stores
okay
and there'll be no billboard app much
like much like alcohol there'll be no
billboard advertising there'll be no
advertising outside that says get this
here get that there just like our stores
this is what you'll see outside of the
store you'll see that brand obviously
with alcohol uh
we have some advertising outside of the
stores but very very little with
cannabis there'll be none
okay uh a couple of questions or a
couple of things I'll come up on this
I'll start with a familiar one uh beside
the signage that the state would approve
it would also have to go through the
local land use board for advertising
because it's not a state they don't have
the
state exemption or governmental
exemption
um
planning board member speaking
the nutritional label uh it's probably
something that we should retain not
because it's a food item because but it
specifies the contents of the material
and indicates that there has been some
testing that has taken place it also
helps to delineate whether it's a high
THC content or a higher CBD content
dependent upon the intended use of the
product
um and from what uh genus of uh cabinet
is the product was derived from I think
that's at nutritional label may be the
wrong terminology content label maybe a
better descriptive term so it does
describe it differently as for child
proof uh containers uh
this uh the the Outline by The Liquor
Commission said it would be opaque so
you're not going to be able to see the
quote unquote Gummies at all it's it's
merely a uh advertised bag over which
that's part of the advertising
rules will set up what that advertising
can say is on that package I know that
some of the packages that present are in
containers
um
and some of the packaging is
in a foil packaging uh some of the quote
unquote candy bars that is chocolate
favorite ones don't look like any candy
bar not even a Hershey bar foreign
two points one related to the
Nutritional labeling I think the what's
envisioned here by the nutritional
labeling is what's we see on the side of
the box of cereal love calories fats and
I would my point is that this doesn't
have nutritional value because I would
imagine that most people are eating one
block of a candy bar is are probably not
going to be worried about the trans fats
that are in it so we wanted would not
imply that this actually is a food item
it's closer to a drug or a medical item
which is actually what it's used as
right now the question that I did have
was about the line between rule making
and statute and this may be just an open
question
uh a lot of what's been discussed today
is our regulations that are going to be
created through rule making which is the
typical process because we don't want a
statue that's 120 pages long
however this would create the awkward
position in which the franchisor or the
Liquor Commission is also creating the
law in enforcing the Law related to its
franchise agreement uh while that is the
what we're doing it right now with the
liquor stores the difficulty becomes now
the federalism question at what point do
the franchisors their franchisees excuse
me become de facto agencies of the state
because we exercise so much control
through administrative law over those
agencies that the federalism issue is
now drawn into question
I would say that's a comp compounded
legal question that you can probably sit
five
knowledgeable Scholars down and you may
get five different conclusions
maybe even six
um there's a couple people illegal
background here I would just tell you I
still I don't personally I understand
there's different levels of control but
whether the state's licensing it for a
private person to do it or they're
selling it themselves directly either
way they're facilitating it one way or
another obviously there's less control
when it's privately done but I still
think in order to do this
the first step that we're doing we're
ignoring federal law and the therapeutic
businesses we're ignoring the federal
law and then putting this together for
the most part at least I'm speaking to
myself I'm ignoring federal law because
this violates federal law in every
aspect possible
that's just my my humble opinion so I
think
you're right there's obviously the more
the state controls it the more they get
kind of
it's implied that they're part of you
know they have an agency relationship
but
I mean if if federal law is an issue for
anyone well we end as we all understand
that it's against it so
that's just where my heads at
thank you for taking my question has
there been any consideration to this
model
um if the federal government does decide
at some point uh to legalize cannabis is
there any risk to this model
no I would think that it's the least
riskiest because the state is separated
from it first and foremost and so
they're private businesses and if we're
allowed to bring product in from out of
state and the interstate transportation
and things like that are null and void
then private businesses remain private
and they consider that there's they stay
in business welcome
thank you Mr chair
um I I was just reading the other day
that in New York uh they have a quasi uh
State cannabis model as well well I I
guess I kind of consider this quasi
um if the state won't have liability but
the governor hokel is being sued by I
think it's six different
um harmed parties so it's not the
federal government these These are civil
suits coming forward and I'm just
curious if
um
if it's called the state of New
Hampshire cannabis outlet and this
franchisees who has the liability uh
should there be a um you know follow-up
lawsuit similar to New York
let the lawyer answer the question I
suppose
um I I don't think you can make that
determination now how would you make
that determination you know what are
these what do these civil suits look
like you know it's an impossible
question for the Liquor Commission to
sort of answer that in a way of which
who who's being sued why they being sued
what's what is the basis of the lawsuit
what are they saying happened where did
they say it happened right okay thank
you
um being that we're knowingly violating
federal law would it be a good idea to
bring the Attorney General we have to
AGN uh as one of our sub uh focus groups
uh to speak to us and answer some of
these questions
of course anyone from that office is
welcome to it at 10 year anytime and we
would welcome them here I think it's
pretty clear that we're filing federal
law so I don't know
but we would obviously want to know what
what their their opinion is on how this
would work if enforcement became an
issue but
I'm just going to go back to I mean
we're filing the therapeutic
industry and I'm not picking on them but
they are violating federal law as we
speak and the state pass laws give them
licenses and allows them to operate so I
guess if we're gonna
I still know it kind of gets a little
tricky we want to draw a line to say I
don't think it's appropriate for the
legislator to draw that line and we want
to enforce these laws and the FEDS but
not this one I mean you want to remain
consistent
okay
okay yes thank you Mr chair I uh I don't
want to put words in your mouth but what
I hear is not necessarily having the he
evaluate whether it's uh you know
whether we're writing federal law but
just exploring
you know when we're developing this
franchise model exploring the legal
issues around that and related to the
federalism questions that representative
raised is that correct exactly my
concern would be where does the
liability lie is it would the state or
is it with the franchisees and
yeah it's a more nuanced question yes
and perhaps a recommendation is a
strongly worded identification clause in
that franchise agreement May
yes
chief
thank you Mr chair for taking my
question for the commission uh with
respect to enforcement how many liquor
enforcement officers do you currently
employee now for liquor enforcement in
the state of New Hampshire
uh change there are 29 at this current
time with sick part-time investigators
and uh follow a question if I may uh how
many inspectors do you intend to employ
on the Cannabis side
that I hear 10 early on
right now
like we don't know how many stores we're
actually going to have so the caveat to
that is of course as you lead your
Manpower in your organization I do the
same with mine so I will have to look at
the model and how many stores are
actually going to be erected on them to
know how many how did the start this is
a start out of that number how am I
going to read it those that get in
number whatever that number
so it would be fair to say then that
those 10 that would be employed in the
Cannabis side would also be required to
be engaged in the enforcement of
whatever testing and Regulatory actions
for transportation
so without a known quantity in terms of
personnel which we all know is is rather
expensive today right
um with 15 gross sales that you're
taking off of the retailers or the
franchisees then it's virtually
impossible to determine what the cost of
Regulation and what that Revenue would
be to the state would that be fair to
say I think the separate number is a
good number compared to the other
identical
models that are out there
franchising but
when you look at how your standard
influence as you do I'm looking at how
many stores one investigator can have
under its control and have a thorough or
have a thorough look at what exactly is
going on inspections what they're doing
on a daily basis to include everything
else that the the consumer is doing
coming in okay so thank you for your
answer and uh but currently the liquor
inspectors are not engaged in testing of
of product that is being sold correct so
they don't they don't go out and would
not be engaged in the same testing
process on as it would be on the
Cannabis side correct
so we'd rely on the ttb to do testing on
alcohol products just like the FDA on
tobacco products we would rely on this
independent
laboratory
to do the testing on the Cannabis firms
so when the products got to the store
Chief they if they they would never get
to the store if they hadn't been
thoroughly vetted and tested just like
Bacardi doesn't get to the Shelf unless
it's thoroughly vetted and tested nor
does any other product new product that
comes along and just to back up for a
minute uh Tina's done some calculations
for me from our standpoint salaries uh
would be about 1.75 million yearly for
these folks additional folks benefits
would be about eight hundred and ten
thousand so the liquor commission's uh
salary and benefits estimate with what
we've put in front of a year is about
2.56 million
thank you commissioner and again that
um
would require regulatory body since
you're not relying on the FDA here to
test this product that there would be a
separate testing regulatory mechanism
that the state would have to ensure it
would be in place and monitor as has
been done in every other state that's
done this
absolutely
thank you thank you so commission I want
to give you a chance to finish your
presentation I have a couple questions I
want to make sure I'm not sure if you're
completely done or not but I will make
one comment relative to
uh the enforcement pieces that again the
Assumption here is 65 maximum stores and
with 65 maximum stores 10 employees
right so there's a ramp up phase here
where we're not going to be at 65 stores
on day one so understand there is a
there is an adjustment period for lack
the better phrase as we start opening
and start doing things so is that is
that correct that's correct I I can't
imagine that we would be at 65 retail
outlets uh five to seven years would be
my estimate on what that would take
thank you so if you if you're finished
I'm not sure if you are
65 was was Max that's correct that's
correct yeah
that's what I'm saying the Assumption of
the 29 employees a 65 full stores we may
not we're not going to get there for a
while but
um that
2.56 million dollars is a graduated
number that's going to ultimately get
there you're saying about five years
you're estimating correct correct can I
follow up some more questions
that so my follow-up to the question was
we kind of skipped over if there was a
section there about municipalities and
what we're doing with municipalities I
miss that part of the conversation it
was on page
15.
on page 13.
so I guess some of my questions revolve
around
um
unlike liquor stores which which means
families don't necessarily have a say in
whether or not they're a lot they're
going to be in there we're going to be
allowing municipalities are requiring
municipalities to have an opt-in vote to
allow for cannabis retailers is that
correct that's correct we're also going
to allow municipalities to have zoning
privileges for lack of a better phrase
around those Cannabis stores correct
that's correct and your understanding is
that you are going to give one percent
of the state's portion of the revenue to
the municipalities I've chosen to opt-in
only not to all municipalities that's
correct thank you
thank you
and you make Famous Recipe nope that's
all we have
um
in your circular like sales to minors in
the enforcement side of that obviously
uh you're dealing with the private
franchisees now
is there any with any comments on having
a rule or which
would have to occur if someone to lose
their connections
what type would it be like a one strike
three-strike system and how would that
work with it I'm sure this
some some more egregious than others at
the violations of that I'm not talking
about someone who comes in with an ID
and some perhaps it makes it pass you
know because it's a big idea I'm talking
about
[Music]
well uh you know as far as a one strike
two strike three strike that's up to the
legislation and the rule that's how that
would that's how that would be governed
were
when you know neutral on how we feel
whatever whatever you feel is best is is
what we put into the rule uh
I I don't think that we have uh given
given thought to the process of the
legislation obviously we want to make
sure that
anybody who does anything egregious
loses their franchise agreement and
these will be a valuable asset this is
an asset of a business just like any
other franchise tool and one of the
reasons we're going in this
direction is because these these
franchise licenses have a value and
they're an asset to a business and I
don't feel that anybody would put them
In
Harm's Way given the amount of Revenue
that potentially could come from them
now as far as where it goes if it's a
one strike it's a one strike if it's a
two strike it's however it needs to be
is there any
is there anything actually
in respect to alcohol and I guess we'll
talk maybe into a think of like a
restaurant right now how many how many
things would have to occur before the
license actually revoked I think it
depends on the
activity in place obviously
you know death resulting are different
than a single over service so I think
that there's a a huge gamut of of how we
look at it it's
okay and James is telling me that it's
an administrative process as well
I think related to this question of how
many strikes would a licensee need to
have before they lost a license perhaps
it's more uh analogous to the liquor
stores if a liquor store were to engage
in a practice that's not allowed by the
commission they use others signed each
other pricing whatever may be how many
times does that franchisee need to poke
the bear so to speak before they lose
their license well the liquor stores
aren't franchise agreements so we own
the liquor stores
and there's there's rules and and
there's uh
laws in place there's legislation in
place that dictates what we need to do
with employees I'm thinking in
particular of the agency stores even
though there aren't that many left this
is probably most analogous to those at
what point what an agency store get
pulled even though it's unlikely the
agency stores are reviewed on a yearly
basis so much like uh these franchise
agreements those licenses are reviewed
on a yearly basis so at the end of the
year if you have if you haven't been a
good operator potentially could you lose
your license and I don't want to speak
for the outline but it's all outlined in
Rural and legislation as to what we do
foreign
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question so I've had the
privilege of meeting some of your liquor
investigators they've come spoke to the
Raymond Coalition for Youth and do stuff
with our town all the time and so I I've
seen what they do when they go out and
they're investigating
um you know say a sale to a minor or
over service so what what what can we
put in place or what do you suggest we
put in place like I mean obviously we
don't want to be selling marijuana to
any minors
um so as for liquor what's the penalty
when you catch a store selling to minors
and
like how how
um like when do they lose their license
or our ability to sell alcohol well
again it depends on the the severity of
what happens there's nothing that's it's
all different levels in different stages
and as far as
you know our thoughts on what the
legislation should look like I have no
idea what the legislation should look
like that's something that I think that
has to be a much broader discussion
yeah so I want to intervene on this
because we actually had this bill in my
committee right now
okay we have an over serving uh
legislation so what I want to say is is
that the the department has rules
already
um there is a thorough investigation in
any any violation and yes there is a
step system we do currently have so I
would think that one of our breakouts
has one of our sessions could be is to a
take that what we're working on and as a
matter of fact we're actually changing
looking at the rules right now A take
that but B look at other states and see
what they have done in terms of their
violations of of the of you know of over
in the in the case of selling to someone
as a underage
um it's hard to say over someone's been
over served
um keep in mind that the biggest
violators of our regulations
are the on-premise
the the restaurants and we don't have
any of those
you know we don't you don't have
on-premise you know all those licensees
that that all those Regulators all those
guys enforcement are going we don't have
any of those in this legislation so you
know I mean that takes out a big chunk
of what the problems are but I think
that this is worth
um a
sessions just to look at what those
penalties are because that's an
important issue that needs to be
addressed what what will be the
violations so the franchisees need to
know up front and the legislature has
spoken and weighed in on exactly uh how
many times they can screw up before they
lose their franchisee I agree there's
also a branding issue because these
franchise franchisees are all going to
be operating on the same logo so you
have one or two
that are we should say run poorly
you can perhaps hurt the ones that are
being run
you know following all the rules and I
think at the time because we have a
brand right now that doesn't have any
brand identity so I think it's important
to maybe so yeah so when the Liquor
Commission does do these things for
under under the under 8 21. they usually
if there's a liquor store in that
Community the day are part of that sting
so that they're not they they don't get
out and but yes if if an employee if a
liquor store wherever to do it and I
don't think I've ever heard of a case
but yeah they get fired on the spot
right because they would be damaging our
reputation in this case I guess
the retail store wouldn't be an employee
right exactly but I I assume that person
would be fired anyway but that's that's
I would imagine the discussion first
everything that we do is done by a
legislative process
so and it's correct that it's a it's a
step process but in writing a franchise
agreement
that's where you would cover this to say
if you have an employee that does this
this is what needs to happen if you have
an employee that does that this is what
needs to happen but I do think we should
probably cover I agree I have that
resolved but that's this legislation
that's something that comes out of the
committee that uh engages us to write
the franchise agreement the way we feel
it needs to be written
the way you all feel it needs the way it
needs to be written thank you thank you
Mr chair so
um again I I you have history in doing
this enforcement obviously with all your
licenses how many liquor licensees do we
have in the state of New Hampshire 6100
so 6100 agency you know organizations
are already we're talking about 65 here
so maximum 65. so you have
um already experience in dealing with
what is a low moderate and severe uh
violation and and suspending those
licensees which I you do on a fairly
regular basis you know when you find a
incident so I think we're in the right
agency to manage that I also know that
we identify the same exact thing in in
our charitable gaming organizations
right we have when you can suspend a
charitable gaming license we have
controls and conditions for that as well
as to when charitable gaming operator's
license is suspended so I think that um
it's it's the right place I think I'll
utilize some of the same exact rules I'm
assuming it just modified to met deal
with marijuana versus Liquors is that
fair to say that's fair to say thank you
very much and
1250 or so of those licenses are out of
state licenses so we're one of the 13
states that allows uh wine to be shipped
into the state as well that has to be
monitored by The Liquor Commission as
well
thank you how you doing good question
for you certainly
um and it's maybe I'm not there so I see
the 15 gross months monthly sales that's
good
um are we not selling how much is this
license going to cost so if I'm the guy
who gets the dairy license that's worth
a lot of money to me and are we like the
liquor licenses are 175 to 500 this
seems like geez I should be a cabbies
license in New York is a million dollars
shouldn't I be getting a big bundle up
front when I'm giving someone a
franchise agreement if I was getting a
Burger King I'd have to pay two three
million dollars absolutely we'd be
getting a bundle of money from every
franchise eight well on top of what I'm
saying absolutely and I completely agree
we I have looked at it a couple of
different ways but I think that uh
obviously it will be an asset of the
business and obviously it'll it'll have
a salable value and the longer the
longer the business runs the more the
vet the more value of that asset is
worth uh the idea is uh twenty five
thousand dollars for the license for the
first year uh they'll obviously be a fee
to apply for the license you'll have to
be a good sound character
Financial financially solvent
etc etc year 2 12 5 year 3 6250 year 4
31.25 and year five and beyond that
twenty five hundred dollars a year so
the licenses would be twenty five
thousand dollars a piece for the first
year
they're doing the build up
an absolute the the the build out for uh
a facility to manufacture is would be a
minimum of a million dollars probably
closer to three to two manufacturing
growing but the retail exactly I would
figure somewhere between 750
000 and a million two depending on the
size of your store to build out and that
will as far as we are concerned we will
do an RFP for all of the furniture and
fixture so you go into any store they
absolutely look the same just like when
you go into our liquor Outlets all the
ones that we've redone have a look and a
feel and they will no one will be able
to open a store
or sell a product until obviously we
inspect it and the process has gone
through where they buy the product
through the vendor that's chosen by the
Liquor Commission and or vendors that
are chosen by the Liquor Commission
in respect to all the stores looking the
same I and I I totally agree with the
franchise model that's how it should go
the only I think maybe
odd issue you may run into is the
therapeutic industry if one of those
entities were let's say apply for the
franchise and then obtain it
would their facility have to change they
have to have a separate retail store how
would that unfold
and that's that's an area well I I think
that if they're going to have a retail
end of it or would have to mirror the
outlet model if they had a therapeutic
part of the business that would be one
thing and and the retail model would
have to would have to mirror it
obviously could only could be a portion
of what they have it could be something
that's divided and they could have a
separate store
so there would be some sort of an
expense
there you go
Mr jackass I was gonna actually had
notes to make sure we involve maybe
bring DHHS to the next meeting to see
how in a ATC how it could possibly
become a retail store on what that would
look like in order to keep our medical
industry as vibrant as possible as well
chief
and thank you Mr chair not a question
but a comment just circling back to
um the penalty discussion that my
recommendation would be that
um there would be a focus meeting or a
group that looks at fine penalties uh to
ensure compliance with respect to not
only the dispensation but also because
the state's engaged in purchasing that
it
enveloped the entire regulatory process
to ensure compliance
so more than just franchisee compliance
but there would be growing testing
compliance and so forth as part of the
penalty structure of fine and fee
foreign
thank you Mr chair I have a I just
wanted to follow up to Senator Whitley
spoke earlier about the surge in
childhood poisoning so this is a child
safety issue
um I I realize that we have a the
warning labels which is you know
basically Keep Out Of Reach of children
uh there's I I know currently with the
ATC we have an ATC in in Plymouth it's
ineffective in in many situations we had
two years ago we had four toddlers in
our local Ed in THC induced Comas so
what we're talking about here is edible
products with high THC content updates
um I know we're going we'll we'll be
bringing in some subject matter experts
from other states that have legalized my
question is is I'm not even sure if we
can
um at this point in time find this
information but what products
I'm assuming they're Edibles we're not
going to see for four-year-olds vaping
oh two-year-olds
um so they must be like brownies or
gummies or something along that line is
there any way we can revisit current
legislation with the atcs and also in
designing this legislation we look to
child safety in in limiting those
products if we can determine what they
are that our young children Toddlers and
young children are attracted to and and
ingesting so it obviously it'll have an
impact on profitability but
um
we can't put a cost on our on all young
children's lives at some point we're
going to lose a child and so we we need
to look at
look at this as we're investigating it
um to limit these products so in respect
to regulating or addressing some of the
regulations that apply the atcs I think
that's a somewhat outside the scope of
the commission I know it's something
important it's an important issue for us
with the goal here is to really set up
this way forward the state-run model but
I think the rules are regulations that
we would support in helping Implement
that state-run model could certainly
address what I would say would be the
the
what we would want that to be and I
would certainly encourage the atcs to
take notice of what that is okay thank
you so
descriptions Alden
Mr chair yeah I have a few questions
here so when you're talking about the
licensing of the respective franchise
franchises
I get sort of visions of sort of The
Medallion system like he like uh Senator
again said so do you envision that as
you charge a fee and then that person
owns it or is it just simply
and then they own it and they can like
transfer it through and sell it to
somebody if they wanted to in a way that
I could sell my house or do you view it
as this is the licensing fee that you
have and then if I exit the business I
can't sell to somebody else but I have
to give it back to you guys to reuse
no the license you'd own the license you
would on the license that's right
franchise you don't the franchisee would
own the license now in the franchisee
goes to sell the license obviously
whoever purchases it has to go through
the approval process again
and start with the process of paying for
the license again okay so if that
license today you sell it to them for 25
000 or whatever you settle on and they
listed out a bunch of numbers then if
that becomes if this becomes like just a
booming industry that license becomes
worth a million dollars that's my
million dollar asset that follows me
around right that's correct
okay and then
um we've talked a lot about the stores
but like how do you envision the the
regulation of who gets to like produce
it grow it and then manufacture so is
there going to be and then distribution
I guess so are you guys in charge of
distribution or is that going to be like
a
a licensing system as well for some
distributes as well as growing and then
just the processing of the of the grown
product no much like the New Hampshire
Wineries and distilleries are allowed to
self-distribute in the state the
manufacturers and The Growers would be
allowed to self-distribute in the state
and so who how would the have we do we
have a good framework yet of how we
would decide how many Growers it can be
or is it just anybody to try it
unlimited okay the toughest piece in in
this industry is and the mistake a lot
of states have made is they've looked at
profit first and they've looked at
safety second and the other the other
biggest piece is that they're in such a
rush to make the money
they don't have enough product to sell
Vermont ran out of product in five days
when they opened so one of the thing is
to make sure that you have enough
Growers to supply the need for whatever
amount of stores you have in your first
wave which I would imagine would be five
or six
okay thank you I mean the not just I I
don't want to get into the number part
of the number part of it but we have to
because the numbers are staggering the
sales are staggering and let's let's
look at Massachusetts just as a quick
example in 2019 Massachusetts did 400
million dollars in sales
2020 did 702 million dollars in sales
and in 2022 they're gonna they did a
hundred they did
1.75 billion dollars in sales so that's
Massachusetts they charge a 6.5 percent
excise tax which in 2022 uh was 109
million to the state and the 10 points
five percent 10.7 percent
X size which is 1.57 million to the
state so 6.25 sales tax 109 million in
10.7 excise tax
1.57 million to the state so uh I just
I've been
to to Maine and I've been to uh to
Vermont and I've been to Massachusetts
uh there's a staggering number of uh New
Hampshire plates wherever you go so that
from a revenue standpoint
but I I wanted to just bring those
numbers to you because those are
in my humble opinion staggering numbers
so I think that it's something that we
have to um
I I would make it make a suggestion that
we can get your Rel The Regulators from
these respective States and I know we
talked about Quebec last time because I
do a state-run model but it'd be great
to hear from them directly I think if we
could schedule that on to Future
meetings I don't have a problem with
that I'll be curious I like to confirm
that some of those Regulators will be
willing to come testify because you know
we're summoning competition with each
other yeah yeah just to point that out
is just to clarify when you said self
self-distribute uh manufacturer
cultivator could do that you were
suggesting that if a cultivator can sell
their own grow on site make their own to
in a retail capacity per se but not
necessarily operated free kind of like a
winery right now sells their own product
on site but
no the
manufacturers and The Growers will have
the option to have a retail license if
they choose to have a retail license
it's a separate license obviously it's a
separate fee but those products that
they grow and manufacture what they can
self-distribute to the the retailers the
franchisees just like you know LaBelle
Winery sells at her at her different
facilities but she also sells in the New
Hampshire liquor store she sells in the
grocery stores convenience stores she's
able to self-distribute her product
throughout the state but I believe
particularly has a retail component to
it where it does so would would a
cultivator have that same
assuming the zoning allows for it yeah
yes and my idea that yes they would but
it's obviously the legislation that
questions come up a lot so whatever
direction we go without you need to be
buried so they would not be agency
stores per se but they that you can sell
your own product in your location give
tours you love no tastings
correct we do things but you need to be
clear with that one direction or another
because you are a franchisee and perhaps
if your store is next to or near a
winery and then that that's a
possibility that you understand what I'm
saying is you it that's In fairness to
that person that's invest apparently
over a million dollars into their retail
store right uh but they're near a
cultivation facility and then that
cultivation you want to make sure that
no one can start well I I think that we
would not allow
uh a franchisee to next to a facility
that's a grower a cultivator a
manufacturer and Retail so they would if
that retail they're all separate
licenses but if that grower and
manufacturer chooses to have a retail
license at that location it's something
that's available to them
thank you Mr chair
um just going back to what you said
about
um obviously part of this effort is to
capture some of the revenue that's gone
into our I mean it's undeniable that
part of our motivation here is to keep
this Revenue part of this Revenue in the
state
and it sounds like a lot of Art and I
don't know the proportion I don't think
anyone knows the proportion but a lot of
our revenue is going to Massachusetts
and Maine and Maine do we have a
proportion it's hard to know probably
it's hard I would go to the Senator's uh
comment that their their private
businesses
they're very tight-lipped even to get
the information off the internet Tina
had a very difficult time there's a lot
of information out there it's not a lot
of Revenue information out there right
so in terms of just thinking about this
idea of wanting to capture the revenue I
know a lot of
um
give me a minute
um I
know that a lot of places in
Massachusetts allow online ordering I
don't know how they manage that but um
is that something you all have thought
about for New Hampshire allowing that
online ordering because I know you know
people like that for the convenience and
so that's that's one issue and then
along with that is the sort of inventory
system will the franchisees be required
to have like a standard inventory system
they're that they'll they will use a
system that the Liquor Commission will
use so every franchisee their point of
sale system will be a standard system
that the Liquor Commission chooses and
and uses uh as far as online ordering
and delivery uh as long as it's done
through a licensed carrier which would
be UPS or FedEx and or a W-2 employee
yes they would be able to deliver the
product much like I guess they do in
other states I guess I was talking about
um
so I wasn't talking about like being at
scent places but like you order and then
you walk into the store and you get it
that kind of thing you can do that as
well okay absolutely
yes I do thank you yes one quick
question I know you're running we're
running a little bit late here but
um has there been any thought to uh the
determination of the number of growing
or cultivation licenses that would be
required
um for the State of New Hampshire to
meet its requirements well there's 48 in
Maine at the moment
so
I I haven't we haven't thought that
we have would put some sort of a cap on
it I think it would be something that
we'd have to look at especially if the
demand outweighed the supply the
certainly the worst thing that you can
do in business is to have the locations
open with no product so I think that
would be something that would we would
have to govern specifically just like we
would cover the the retail outlets as
well
so it'd be fair to say then though that
there would be two sides of that
equation meeting demand but yet ensuring
that there isn't so much of an
overabundance of Licensing of
cultivation that it ends up looking like
what we see now in Oklahoma and some
other states where there's been such a
proliferation that the state's been
overrun and that's not even legalized in
Oklahoma would that be fair to say so it
should be a cap based on what the
projected requirement would be I I don't
want to use the word cap Chief with all
due respect I think it's something it's
a business decision that needs to be
looked at I think that the depending on
the demand of the product in in business
it you can't put a cap on it's like
telling Bacardi they can only make so
many bottles that's it because but if
the shelves are empty then there's no
Revenue so the balance here is the
Premier thing is the safety of the
product the revenue and the cultivation
have to go together so if we have the
demand to have 28 cultivators and we
only have three we've got a problem
I'm aware of that it's been a long time
since I took economics in college but uh
supply and demand but also um
suggest if not there be a basis for
ensuring that there's not so much
cultivation that is over cultivation and
that reduces the the excess demand
excess Supply actually reduces the cost
correct yeah thank you
I think you think this chip just just a
quick response to this term cap I think
create the cap creates an official
situation that becomes very dangerous in
the entire process it creates a series
of inequities to begin with of capping
capping is something that you have to be
very careful uh in in looking at just
wanted to make that comment
thank you thank you
thank you Senator I just wanted to uh
clarify what I just heard a few minutes
ago um so we were talking about limiting
the number of stores through this
proposal and so that we could kind of
not become Massachusetts and have a
store on every corner but what I I think
what I just heard is that the
cultivators could then automatically
become retail locations no not
automatically the cultivators can apply
for a retail license so if we're trying
to limit the number of stores and we
have unlimited cultivators then we're
not really limiting the number of stores
no we have the we have the option to
give those cultivators a retail license
or not I'm sure some of them they won't
want it and I'm sure some of them will
so I think that as per as far as to the
point of how many cultivators do we
allow
that's a decision that needs to be made
based on how much product we sell
if we're constantly running out of
product we need more cultivators now
although every single one of those
cultivators want a retail license
perhaps not
thank you so we've been talking a lot
about money about my I can't calculate
what 2.5 million dollars in sales equals
in tonnage marijuana for growth is there
a way of of calculating that out and
figuring out what we think we might need
for the number of Acres number of plants
number of whatever we want to qualify it
as to get to what we think that
cultivation industry is going to look
like I think we'd have to rely on the
consultant for those those types of uh
metrics it's not something that the
Liquor Commission is privy to
so again my understanding is in every
state it's state regulated for the
retail side so we know from seed to sale
what that product looks like at a state
level so we should be able to base on
our states do a simple calculation of
how much how much bud do they have in
and and to create that Revenue so we can
get an estimate of what that looks like
I would say that's a safe assumption
senator
which I guess I'd like that information
when you get it that's how much how much
material do we need to generate X number
of dollars in Revenue because again
other states have similar models we know
what the sale looks like and what the
how much product they need to sell to
create that so if we could find out that
number I'd appreciate that so I
understand what cultivation looks a
little more like in New Hampshire
okay so unfortunately I have to leave
it's noon
um what I'm hearing here is we we're
learning a lot of important things that
we want to make sure are included in our
discussion and so I was aware that we
did the minutes we're talking let's go
through a bill so what I would like to
see is maybe is for all the committee
members and actually members of the
audience and anybody who wants their way
in is to go through 1598 look in there
and see what things are there
things that you don't like
we like to have recommendations to fix
it
okay so please put your thinking cap on
and tell us how you think it should be
better or different use you can use the
other Bill any bills any ideas you have
anything that you see that there is in
it or not in it you know let's write
them all down and then put that together
and that way we can have a good plan
going forward about how many special
sessions we need on what sections but
also to know what parts of the build
that we're we're okay with as a working
model and that's just a recommendation
and just like the very first I want the
first page well the definition section I
know the definition of cannabis in and
of itself as an issue so it's
we'll cover that
um but other than that I have to go
there's anyone else in the committee
have any any comment on that I mean
obviously I was I was hoping to go
through 1598 today and just to clarify
to the people listening at home and
here in attendance it's 15 HP 1598 from
last term but it's what passed as
amended in the house there's a few
different versions of that but
ultimately the one that made it out of
the house and failed in the Senate that
you want to get that version that's that
was latest working version of that bill
customer using 59 user basis and looking
ready modifications in the members of
the commission should have a side by
side with
Senate Bill 98 that has has a
that was an amendment 20448
I have it was distributed last time I
believe but I I'll make sure I'll make
sure you get a copy
I know representation you have to leave
but is there any
uh is there any point of us maybe
perhaps going through the definition
section starting going through 590 is a
long bill how about set the date for the
next meeting
right we can do that Chief right
um I I just wonder whether or not it's
appropriate to go through 1598 before
we've heard from some of the focus
groups regarding some of the other
Salient issues that are in 1598 that we
haven't heard and haven't flushed out
yet
I think what we want to do is as we're
going through 1598 you know obviously we
would welcome some comments from anyone
that's
that perhaps if we kind of run into some
application issues on how it would apply
uh we're still going to have those
hearings with the public can kind of
address some of those concerns we run
into nothing set in stone but
uh putting forward a model that would
actually work what it what is inside
that that doesn't work that we already
know and I'm sure the people that are
listening now are probably gearing up
with questions as we speak
but that's just my people has any
comment on that
um Mr chair just to follow up Chief
um I'm wondering what the thinking is
and what the rationale is to look at
legislation that failed
and have that inform our next steps
rather than listening to a stakeholder
and subject matter experts from the
other states let them inform uh our
input into 1598 after the fact it seems
like we're kind of putting the cut
before the horse
yeah it just may come at 1598 never was
voted on
the amendment you see in front of you
this 1598 Amendment okay what this
amendment was was original Bill the
original as it was submitted house was
not a franchise bill
it was a a direct retail okay so this
amendment was drawn up to take what was
passed by the house overwhelmingly
but to fix it so that it would be a
franchise bill so it really is a very
new piece of legislation that's never
been seen by anybody
and by any any uh you know the committee
the Commerce Committee decided not to
vote for it because they didn't have
time to go through it right uh thank you
representative one one further question
um if we're bringing in um subject
matter experts from Canada and other
states that have implemented models
isn't it you know
a wise use of time to wait and and then
examine this and build upon it so I was
uh well I agree with you so and maybe I
wasn't you know specifically declare
what I was saying and that is that I was
hoping people would go through all the
bills find the things that you like and
you don't like make a list of it then
when we do our next meeting we can go
through and schedule and figure out what
needs to be heard who we can hear from
and figure that out then after we've
gotten that advice and after we've
gotten pieces that we all can agree on
like if whatever was enforcement
penalties or whatever decision that we
decide we'd like then we go through the
bill and and and put it into the
legislation I think the point
representative Hunt's making is 1598 the
retail the definition of a retail store
was a state-run store and right off the
bat that won't work I think kind of the
goal would be even maybe merge that
language merge the franchise language
into this this bill and at that point in
time we then go through it again a
second time where we're going to have
the public comment on
subsections of that bill because and
we're kind of just using that as a
template to start discussion I don't to
get it off this is going to be a
comprehensive piece of legislation if
one were to go forward so so we're not
actually it feels like we're writing
legislation rather than given a report
that that's that's my major concern that
is the goal of this commission
the charge of the commission is to put
together legislation which does not mean
someone supports the legislation I would
emphasize putting something together
we've got to make sure that this could
actually operate in reality I I my
weight is that it's proposing
legislation not necessarily writing
legislation they're two two separate
two different things I just want to
clarify
so I just just to clarify I'm looking at
the actual statute
and it says the commission we're
establishing a commission to study with
the purpose of proposing legislation
State controlled sales and then if you
look at what we shall do the commission
shall study with the purpose of
proposing legislation so is your point
that we're sort of putting the cart
before the horse we need to do more
study before we focus on yes
so a middle ground is let's do some more
study before we're actually getting to
the nuts and bolts of the legislation I
think what we do is we have a base model
you study
and then because whatever whatever com
whatever we kind of come up with I'm
fairly confident will not be the final
product because we could just sit down
tomorrow and craft legislation uh
without hearing any input but that's
that's not the purpose of a study
commission right well when I was
envisioning correct if I'm wrong here is
once you have some baseline of what the
proposed legislation could be then you
hear comments on what that is but right
now anything that they comment on I
don't and representative correct if I'm
wrong I know 1598 doesn't have anything
about franchise agreements in there and
obviously the canvas definition do they
call them an agency store but yeah
the the key element is what I was
looking for when I say that was I want
whatever issues that you really care
about
I want you to make sure you've let us
all know ahead of time let us know what
they are and if you have suggested
language that you would like to see in
Lane in the bill to address the issue
you care about
tell us sooner rather than later and
that's the same thing for the chief
saying for ACLU everyone has got their
things that they're really important to
them and I think that that when and I've
been doing this for a while that when we
when I put a bill together I I need the
pieces and then when we start building
it is all those blocks are there and I
can then we can then insert them and
make sure they're in the right place and
it makes sense rather than someone come
along afterwards and say oh but I want
to consider this and wait a second you
know please tell us up front what you're
interested so I'm I'm also thinking in
terms of what's in here now maybe
already address what you want but if it
doesn't tell us sooner rather than later
that's what I was looking for yeah Mr
chair I think um the point uh here is
that using today's example there was
um
um a lot of information that um thanks
to Liquor Commission folks brought
forward today that would in um that
would be used uh to review that section
of 1598 as opposed to how regulation
should look like and I think the point
is that to be able to credibly look at
other pieces of that legislation there
perhaps may be a need for some
additional study in certain areas before
we start because clearly there were a
lot there was a lot of information that
was brought forward today that disposed
of some questions and probably created
some question which I think is helpful
when when you look at so in terms of
efficiency perhaps that's a more
efficient way of doing it rather than
going through it and then having to
Circle back once we've heard from
somebody else well we we didn't think
about that particular element
any any other comment
rips and kale yeah
are we do you think we should be hearing
some from some federal agencies to come
in and talk to us about the
transportation factor of this I mean
like what happens when we sell to a
Canadian Citizen and they try and cross
the border you know I mean like are we
going to rough follow some stuff there
um you know uh it's great that we're
talking about franchises like McDonald's
and all these places but those are all
legal items
like those like selling alcohol and
transferring alcohol across state lines
or I don't know about transferring
alcohol across International lines but
um those are all legal items right we're
talking about creating a franchise to
sell an illegal item and then transfer
it across possibly state lines with our
customers right
and international ones I think in
respect to that issue I'm not against
any any from the feds federal government
which is to offer their input I'm sure
who would welcome it but right now the
state law I don't know about Maine's but
I know when Massachusetts first had
retail they were only allowed to sell it
to Massachusetts residents and as we
heard
the amount of
cars
that were in the plate now that's
incorrect someone please tell me I'm not
is that not accurate oh that was not
true that's not true okay well so
there's no restriction on who
Massachusetts Institute there's no
restriction on who main sells it to
yeah the only requirement is that before
you get into the facility you have to
show your driver's license and and then
and make sure you're 21. but they do not
look at what state your license was
issued in they they don't they don't
seem to care
all right well in that case but I also
say yes I just so you all know that the
Biden Administration is really apt to
make sure that that it's moved from
schedule one to schedule three within
the next year
so I would say by the time this
commission is done we will probably have
already that that scheduling have
already been reduced perhaps we've just
taken into consideration maybe if you
have a US government issued IDs that I
think he's interested in running winning
reelection and he thinks that this is an
election issue to get marijuana legal Mr
chair if I can step away from the
politics
um down that rabbit hole pretty fast
um so for next meeting
um I think there was a request to have
DHHS here with medical cannabis
licensing to make sure there's no
conflict between medical cannabis and
what would a retail relation looks like
because I know under medical they have
to have a not-for-profit status and how
does that play into having a retail
location so we probably need to have
that conversation we have the AG come in
to talk about the legal liability of the
state and what we think that looks like
and maybe a part of that Transportation
conversation can happen there and then
the last piece of the day was going to
be talking about 1598 and pieces people
may want to add in or expand out or have
a conversation about what that would
look like so the question is how long do
you think it's going to take us to go
through 5098 and all the problems it has
or had
as we try to
well my question is by having covering
well there might be some low-hanging
fruit we can see right away Senator
covering three topics you know whether
it's about DHHS Transportation the
Attorney General on top of going through
1598 kind of to see where it's at where
we have the problems with it
from a time scale I mean
support I I I can handle a four hour
meeting I can handle a six-hour meeting
I'm speaking for myself I need the rest
of you to be able to
tell me you can handle that as well
yes I would request that we just to
respect all the committee members I
think we should separate this continued
sort of study from the really starting
to get into the bill that said I hear
representative hunt saying it's a good
idea to look at that all the members
should look at it and see if there's
areas we need to expand upon but I don't
think we should go line by line until we
have had a fair number of study meetings
Best of Both Worlds
all right so I think what we'll do
suddenly just repeat the agenda see you
again welcome job DH suggests to bring
uh whoever's in charge of medical
cannabis licensing product to talk about
a franchise model and how to integrate
with that medical model if we allow
thc's to do it the second piece to have
the Attorney General to come in and just
do a legal liability for the state
conversation
and then the members of the members of
the commission we will all be looking at
obviously we'll have a chance to review
1598 as amended if anyone doesn't have a
copy of that we can provide to you and
maybe point out some glaring problems
with that bill
that we could perhaps use that for
future agendas did you miss with your
show 1598 was just doing that he's been
talking about high points where we need
deeper study where we have conflict of
language that kind of thing and I
believe the transportation should be
maybe they have the Attorney General
General comment on that yep under the
state legal I vote all right so when
when is the next date that everyone's
available
I think two weeks out is a good time
I'm not available on the second until 11
30.
as well
on the on the third I could do 11
o'clock between 11 and 3.
picture the afternoon
Tuesday afternoon for me but
can't do Tuesday afternoon Tuesday
afternoon I have a meeting with the
governor in the morning
we don't even hear everyone's schedules
you can just say you're unavailable I'm
unavailable Monday afternoon okay so
Monday afternoon on October 2nd doesn't
work correct
so the third afternoon does work though
we're like starting at 11 o'clock no all
right
is that permitted
we're not voting anymore
provide information fourth in the
morning works
it's what time I have another commission
meeting on the fourth so
I think we let's go with the second how
many people aren't available I mean
a bit unavailable I'm not available on
the afternoon of the second I teach yes
can we 10 o'clock work 5 30.
I have a meeting until 11 30. the
council for thriving children which is
you know a government it goes to 11 30
on Monday morning
you wanted 11.
stay here until it sounded like we had
consensus problems
Thursday the 5th Thursday
that works for me
up until three
but he can't do Thursday
there you go there we go
so you wanted to do more than just about
um
I'm trying to accommodate my my friend
to my left here oh um
I should briefly drove here today but we
wanted to build this
Uber
Mr chairman
so what do we end up on let's go
Thursday
um
but okay
Mr chair just have a question about on
on the fifth
um would we be able to look at the
proposed schedule in advance for
bringing in uh some of the um
stakeholders that will be speaking to
the subtopics
I would just say this if there's any
stakeholders that have availability
issues perhaps just communicate that to
the commission on what dates are
convenient because obviously we value
their opinion uh we have to obviously
accommodate everyone's schedule here but
if it's really related to their topic
and they have a limited schedule we'll
do our best to accommodate that they
just need to communicate to the board
and please communicate to the entire the
entire commission so we we all know it
okay thank you any other comments before
we
um
it happens anyway any other question
representative
on the 5th
if you have anything that you wish to
address with you know just communicate
with us and we'll be sure to capture
those concerns I think as of now that we
cannot we can call it a day and we'll
take everyone for coming I think
what do you think
give me give me a call please